GOOD AFTERNOON -- THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE ORDER --
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA START A SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
I WILL I HAVE I HAVE A LINK
THE I GUESS THE CONSTRUCTIONS
I HAVE TO READ THAT NOWADAYS
SO -- WILL READ THAT THROUGH
AND HOPEFULLY MORE MEMBERS
WILL COME IN HI GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME BACK DUE TO ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
AND THE HEARING IN PERSON MASS
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY FIVE THE CAPITAL
AND AT THE REMOTEST TWENTY
STATION ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
YOU CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON IN
THE HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWENTY FOUR TO SIX TO THIRTY
SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S TWENTY FOUR
TO SIXTY THIRTY SEVEN FOR EACH
BIT BILL BEING DISCUSSED TODAY
THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TO PROVIDE TWO
MINUTES EACH OF COMMENTARY
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
CALLING INTO THE PHONE LINE
WILL BE PLACING QUEUE UNTIL
YOU OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS AVAILABLE
PLEASE MAKE YOUR DEVICE TO
REDUCE SOUND DISTORTIONS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE BLENDED
ON THE PHONE LINE PLEASE BE
BRIEF AND LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
I ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE THREE AGAIN THAT'S
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE THREE AND OUR
STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP THANK
URGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FINALLY THE
ASSEMBLY HAS THIS EXPERIENCE
A NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS AND DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED SAYS CONJURE SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE MOVING
OF MASS IN REFUSING TO PUT
IT BACK ON TALKING OR MAKING
LOUD NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING
OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN TIME ALLOTTED
EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR BILL AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS TO ADDRESS
ANY DECEPTIVE CONDUCT SO
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS IF
ANY INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED AND
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS
MAY RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING I ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD AT
THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN
THE NATURE OF THIS DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT AND I MAY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING IF
NECESSARY THE PRODUCT IS
NOT STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS
AND ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL
FROM THE CAPITOL BUILDING I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
COOPERATION BEFORE WE GET
STARTED I WANT TO NOTE THAT
LAST NIGHT MARTIN MARTY WAX
PASSED AWAY MARTY WAS A MEMBER
OF THE PEER REVIEW GROUP THAT
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
HE WAS ALSO A DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF CIVIL
AND EMERIC VARMA ENGINEERING
AND OF CITY AND REGIONAL
PLANNING AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY WHERE
HE DIRECTED THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION CENTER HE
EARLIER SPENT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AT UCLA WHERE HE WAS CHAIRMAN
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF URBAN
PLANNING FOR ELEVEN YEARS HE
HAS MORE RECENTLY BEEN TEACHING
AND CONDUCTING RESEARCH
AT UCLA AND TRANSPORTATION
POLICY HE WAS A LEADER IN
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND THE STATE HAS
GREATLY BENEFITED FROM HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH THAT WE'LL
BEGIN OUR HEARING WE HAVE ONE
SO NOT YET SO WE WILL MOVE
TO AS A SUB COMMITTEE WE HAVE
A NUMBER MEMBERS ON
CONSENT AWAY FOR QUORUM OF THAT
BUT WILL START AND- WE'LL START
WITH ACTUALLY UP ONLINE SIX
MISTER SALAS. A. B. TEN THIRTY
FIVE YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN READY
THIS IS AWESOME RIGHT THANK YOU
RICHARD THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO REPRESENTS- TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BEFORE YOU
STATUS QUORUM. MEMBERS SURE
PERCENT SIMPLY BILL TEN THIRTY
FIVE WILL HELP THE STATE MEET
ITS ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS BY
REQUIRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO ADOPT THE SAME RECYCLED
MATERIAL STANDARDS AS CALTRANS.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR INPUT. AND
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS
MEASURE- WELL MUCH PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE. IN RECYCLING THESE
MATERIALS ABOUT A MILLION TIMES
ARE STILL SENT TO LANDFILLS.
EACH YEAR. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE CITIES AND COUNTIES ALLOW
AT LEAST THE SAME PERCENTAGE OF
RECYCLED MATERIALS FOR
AGGREGATE BASE. HOT MIX ASPHALT
UNRESOLVED APOLOGIZED TO ME
SEVENTY FOUR BEFORE YOU PLACE.
I'M AFFECT ACOSTA RECALLED ROLE
PLEASE. FRIEDMAN. PAUL HERE
BERMAN YOUR CUNNINGHAM. DALY
DAVIES. GIPSON KALRA. LEE
MEDINA. NAZARIAN WHEN. DONALD
LORD. WICKS. ALL RIGHT HI I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THIRTY ONE TO
BEGIN AGAIN I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- BY- SIX AB TEN
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THIS BILL REQUIRE THAT
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CITIES
AND COUNTIES ALLOW AT LEAST THE
SAME PERCENTAGE OF RECYCLED
MATERIALS FOR AGGREGATE BASE
HOT MIX ASPHALT MINOR CONCRETE
RECLAIMED FLY ASH IN RETURN
PLASTIC CONCRETE AS CALTRANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THE MOTION AND SECOND- THIS
AUTHOR HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THREE I BELIEVE
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE LINES
OKAY- I WE HAVE A TO THE
OPERATOR I BELIEVE WE HAVE
CHARLIE RAY- IN SUPPORT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN CHARLIE BY.
THANK YOU VERY WIDE OPEN.
THAT'S RIGHT YOU HAVE TO THAT
IS THAT CHARLIE RIGHT. THE
CHARLIE RAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION. OR
CALCIUM A FOR SHORT THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR COMPANIES THAT
MAKE AGGREGATES ASPHALT AND
CONCRETE. THESE ARE PRODUCTS
ARE USED TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING ROADS
BRIDGES RAIL TRANSIT BIKEWAYS
AND WALKWAYS. THE MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
INCORPORATING RECYCLED
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS SUCH AS
RECYCLED CONCRETE ASPHALT INTO
THEIR PRODUCTS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES. THIS HELPS
CONSERVE NATURAL RESOURCES KEEP
HEAVY AND BULKY MATERIALS OUT
OF LANDFILLS REVIEWS OF THE OIL
AND CEMENT AND REDUCES
GREENHOUSE GASES.CALTRANS HAS
ALSO DEVELOPED. REGRESS AND
THEN STANDARD SPECIFICATIONS
GOING TO MULTI YEAR PROCESSES
TO ALLOW THE USE OF RECYCLED
MATERIALS AND PAVEMENTS WHILE
MAINTAINING THE STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY OF CALTRANS PROJECTS.
WHILE MANY CITIES AND COUNTIES
USE THOSE SPECIFICATIONS A
LOCAL PROJECTS OTHERS EITHER
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT THE USE OF
RECYCLED CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CITIES AND
COUNTIES SHOULD HAVE
SPECIFICATIONS EQUIPMENT TO
CALTRANS STANDARD SPECIFICATION
FOR THE USE OF RECYCLED
MATERIALS AND ROAD BASE ASPHALT
AND CONCRETE. THERE ARE THREE
IMPORTANT THINGS I WANT TO NOTE
ABOUT THE BILL ONE THAT THE
RECYCLED MATERIALS WOULD ONLY
NEED TO BE USED FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DETERMINES IT IS
BOTH FEASIBLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE. A TWO THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO CURRENT OPERATING
CALTRANS STANDARD
SPECIFICATIONS. NOT ABOUT
SPECIFICATIONS IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL OR TRIAL STAGE.
AND THIRD IT ALLOWS FOR FUTURE
CALTRANS STANDARD
SPECIFICATIONS ON RECYCLED
MATERIALS TO BE INCORPORATED.
IN SUMMARY WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW FOR AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE USE
OF RECYCLED MATERIALS FOR
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT WORK
WITH THEM. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
CHARLIE- I DON'T BELIEVE ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- DO WE HAVE ANY WHAT IS
OPPOSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED. BUT SEEING OUR HEARING
NO OTHER. WITNESSES OPPOSITION-
WILL GO TO THE PHONES OPERATOR
WHERE YOU- SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC THAT LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
Q. IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT DOWN EIGHTY EIGHT TEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN Q.
OKAY WATCH ONLINE THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'RE SORRY THIRTY SEVEN YEAR
OPEN. HE. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
OKAY AFTERTHOUGHT YOU DON'T
HEAR ON BEHALF OF STOP WASTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHENEVER TONY
LEMOS WITH GRANITE CONSTRUCTION
WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS- THIS IS
MARLON ASPECT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASPHALT PAVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
PEN. THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU OF
MINE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MARC WATTS I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TAUGHT
BLOOMS STEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APOLOGIZE
FOR GOING OUT OF ORDER I DON'T
SEE ANY WITNESSES OR SPEAKERS
IN THE IN THE CHAMBERS. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IN THE REMOTE
WITNESS. TESTIMONY AREA
THIRTEEN NINE- THE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU- C. S. C. IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELECTED SPEAKING
OPPOSITION TO- FILE I'M SIX AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THEIR COMMENTS OKAY. AND WHAT'S
LINE THIRTY MY UNCLE HAD. HI
THIS IS CHRIS PLEA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE WE JUST WANTED TO
CALL TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENT- AS
NOTED THOSE AMENDMENTS WOULD
TAKE THE BILL OUT OF THE SB ONE
REMAINS A REHABILITATION
ACCOUNT SECTION. AND PUT IT IN
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE WERE
SIMILAR MEASURES HAVE GONE IN
THE PAST AND SECOND AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT AND WE
THINK THE AMENDMENTS BETTER
RECOGNIZE LOCAL FLEXIBILITY AND
ENSURE THAT THIS ISN'T A DIRECT
MANDATE TO ALWAYS USE THE
STANDARDS BUT RATHER TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR USE WHERE IT'S
FEASIBLE AND COST EFFECTIVE-
WILL BE EVALUATING THAT REVISED
BILL I THINK OUR ONE REMAINING
CONCERN IS REALLY ABOUT WHICH
SIDE OF CALTRANS SPECIFICATIONS
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT. IS THAT
THE TODAY'S STANDARDS FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR- REALLY WHAT
HAPPENS AT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
DAYS AS RELATED TO FUTURE
STANDARDS SO WE'LL BE LOOKING
AT THAT BUT WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT HAVE ALREADY
GONE INTO IMPROVING THE BILL.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SEEING IS THERE ANY OTHER
COLORS IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR.
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY I
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW WILL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
TO ANY OF THE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NINE- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND- WHICH I COULD CLOSE
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. FOUR
FIVE FOUR NINE BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON- GIPSON HI KALRA. KALRA
HI WE- MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN I WOULD DONALD. THE DONALD
HI LORD. WARD I WICKS WICKS.
THE VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO. TWELVE
ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS BUT A MOTION
AND SECOND ON CONSENT CONSENT
ITEMS LITTLE THE MOTION IS
SECOND- THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
ACR THIRTY TWO- FILE ITEM ONE
BOMB TO ACR FORTY NINE THREE
EIGHTY NINE FIVE FIVE- FILE
ITEM FIVE AB SEVEN FOUR FOUR.
FIVE SEVEN ACR FORTY SEVEN- I
THINK I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA. THE ITEMS
ON CONSENT FRIEDMAN FONG HI
FONG AYE BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI DALY.
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES AND I
GIPSON- GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA I
WE- MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN. WHEN I O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL HIGH COURT. LORD I
WICKS HI WEEKS HI. THE VOTERS
TO ZERO TWO OKAY WE'LL LEAVE
THAT MOTION I BELIEVE THAT- BUT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
APOLOGIZE TO THE AUTHOR WILL
NEVER DIED AND FOUR FIVE FOUR
AB NINE SEVEN FOUR. YOU MAY
BEGIN RIGHT. SHARE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBER. THANK IN THE CHAIR- AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM ON
THIS BILL I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE
MINERS TO WEAR A HELMET WHEN
RIDING A HORSE AND REQUIRE
REFLECTIVE GEAR- LIGHTS TO BE
WORN BY WRITERS OR THEIR HORSES
AT SUNDOWN. ON AN EVENING IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN A
VEHICLE STRUCK TWO INDIVIDUALS
RIDING THEIR HORSES IN LAKE
VIEW TERRACE IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS CRASH KILLED THE TWO
HORSES AND LEFT THE TWO RIDERS
IN CRITICAL CONDITION MEMBERS
OF MY COMMUNITY WHICH YOU WILL
HEAR FROM SHORTLY BROUGHT THE
SAFETY CONCERNS TO MY
ATTENTION. AFTER RESEARCHING
THIS ISSUE WE FOUND SIMILAR
COLLISIONS IN THE COMMUNITY OF
SAUGUS AND WILTON CALIFORNIA IT
IS NOT UNCOMMON THAT OF COURSE
FOR HORSES TO SHARE THE ROADS
WITH VEHICLES. HOWEVER IT CAN
BE DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO SEE
RIDERS AND THEIR HORSES IN THE
DARK WHEN THESE COLLISIONS
OCCUR THE WRITERS ARE USUALLY
THROWN OFF THEIR HORSES LEAVING
THEM IN CRITICAL CONDITION. THE
HORSES USUALLY DIE UPON
COLLUSION OR MUST BE EUTHANIZED
FROM THE INJURIES THAT THEY
SUSTAINED AB NINE SEVENTY FOUR.
IS A DISTRICT GENERATED
PROPOSAL THAT WILL INCREASE THE
VISIBILITY AND THE SAFETY OF
BOTH OUR EQUINE ANIMALS AND
WRITERS. I'M TODAY I HAVE TO
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE ACTIVE IN
THE EQUINE COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE
BRIEF TESTIMONY I HAVE GENE A
CRUISE AND SHERRY BLOUSE. I
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH- WE
WILL START OPERATIVE WITH-
WHICH INCLUDES. THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GINA CREATED I'M FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF LAKE VIEW TERRACE.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT EIGHT BE NINE
SEVENTY FOUR I LIVE ON A RANCH
NEAR THE QUESTION COMMUNITY AND
THE FROM URBAN AREA OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES WITH MY FAMILY
AND FIVE COURSES. LIKE MANY
EQUESTRIANS WITH THE BERMAN
AREAS MY DAUGHTER AND I
REGULARLY RIDE OUR HORSES ON
CITY STREETS IN ORDER TO ACCESS
OUR LOCAL TRAIL. IT IS VERY
COMMON TO SEE HORSES ON THE
STREETS IN OUR COMMUNITY IN
FACT MANY OF THE STREETS IN OUR
COMUNITY ARE OFFICIALLY
DESIGNATED EQUESTRIAN TRAIL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
BEEN HERE SPINAL TAP ON THE
STREET TO SEPARATE THE
EQUESTRIAN FROM VEHICLE
TRAFFIC. SO WE SHARE THE ROAD
WITH VEHICLES. ABSOLUTE
MENTIONED ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A TERRIBLE ACCIDENT
HERE ON A BUSY STREET INVOLVING
A QUESTIONS IN A VEHICLE. TWO
RIDERS WERE RIDING ALONG
FOOTHILL BOULEVARD AT NIGHT
WHEN THEY WERE STRUCK FROM
BEHIND BY A VEHICLE. THE
WRITERS WERE TRUMP AND
THEREFORE TO THE WORKING NEARLY
INJURED REQUIRING
HOSPITALIZATION. BOTH PARTIES
UNFORTUNATELY WERE KILLED. IF
THE WRITERS HAVE BEEN WEARING
REFLECTIVE GEAR IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT THIS HORRIBLE ACCIDENT
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST SUCH INCIDENT
THAT HAPPENED HERE AND IT
LIKELY WILL NOT BE THE LAST
UNLESS CHANGES ARE MADE. MY
DAUGHTER AND I WERE AT NIGHT WE
ALWAYS VERIFY VESTS AND PUT
REFLECTIVE GEAR ON THE MARKET.
IF THE SMART THING TO DO NOT
ONLY FOR THE SAFETY OF RIDERS
AND HORSES BUT ALSO FOR DRIVERS.
THANK YOU PS WHEN WE'RE ON THE
ROAD AND AVOID A COLLISION. WE
ALSO ALWAYS WEAR HELMET FOR A
BRIDE. FOR THE FLIGHT ANIMAL IT
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO
POTENTIALLY PHYSICAL FORCE. IN
IT THE WRITER COMES OFF THERE
CAN BE SERIOUS RISK OF HEAD
INJURY PARTICULARLY ONE FALLING
ONTO A PAPER OUT. FOLLOW DON'T
CAN MAKE THEIR OWN DECISION ON
THE LEVEL OF RISK THEY WANT TO
TAKE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
CHILDREN BE PROTECTED. BY
REQUIRING THEY WEAR A HELMET
WHEN RIDING ON THE STREET. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
FOUR TO INCREASE THE SAFETY AND
VISIBILITY EQUESTRIANS AND
FORCES. WHEN WE ARE SHARING.
THE ROAD WITH VEHICLES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO SAN. CINDY MAY
PURSUE WHEN YOU'RE READY. THIS
ISSUE RE CLOSE I NEED QUESTRADE
AND REPRESENTATIVE FOR THIS
BILL MAHER NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
AND I'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN THE
EQUESTRIAN COMMUNITY AND SOME
ARE FOR. OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
I WANT TO PARAPHRASE EVERYTHING
THAT WAS SAID RIGHT BEFORE ME
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY
FOUR. ALL RIGHT IN THE STREETS
IN THE EVENING IS TREACHEROUS-
SO MARIN HAS ACCESS YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO ACCESS THE ROAD TO
THE STREETS TO GET TO THE
TRAILS AND- AND IT CAN BE VERY
VERY DANGEROUS- WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL ACCIDENTS IN SOLAAR
WERE AGAIN FORCES AND THE
WRITERS ARE ALWAYS THE LOSERS.
REFLECTIVE GEAR IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDING-
BUT THERE'S BEEN NO ENFORCEMENT
OF IT SO I THINK THAT IN
PASSING THIS BILL IT WILL
ENCOURAGE ALL OF THE RIDERS TO
WHERE THEY IN FACT IT
REFLECTIVE GEAR ON THEMSELVES
AND ON THE HORSES. I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND YOU VOTE FOR THIS.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION LIFTED- OPERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE- I KNOW WHAT IT
IS OPPOSITION SO- WE'LL NOW
MOVE- I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBERS- SPEAKING- WILLING
WAITING TO SPEAK IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE. TESTIMONY
AREA SEEING AND HEARING ON THE
CHAIRS BACK OF MY HAND DO YOU
WANT ME TO GO AHEAD OF PROCEED
FORWARD. WE HAVE MOTION SECOND-
WILL GO TO THE OPERATOR IS
THERE ANY- ANYONE OF THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF- THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT THE NINE SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- WITHOUT WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE WE HAVEN'T DONE
THAT FOR ANY QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR YOUR SUPPORT- ON BEHALF OF
THE EQUESTRIAN COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK- YOU AND OTHERS ON THE
COMMITTEE. OF THE QUESTION
COMMUNITY AND MY DISTRICT IS
ONE OF THE LAST AFFORDABLE.
PLACES TO OWN A HORSE IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- AND IT AND
BECAUSE WE SHARE ROADS WITH
CARS- IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE- TO ASSURE. THAT THERE
IS SAFETY IN THIS COMMUNITY
WHILE WRITING. OF EQUINE
ANIMALS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
INTO MY HORSE IS A RESIDENT OF
YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL- SO.
DEFINITELY HAVE A LITTLE BEFORE
THE RACE HERE HI WITH THAT CAN
WE OPEN THE ROLE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
CUNNINGHAM. I CUNNINGHAM AYE
DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON- GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA
KILEY. MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN. WHEN I O'DONNELL. DONALD
I WARD. WARD I WICKS THANKS HI.
FIVE TEN. THE VOTERS THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU. UP NEXT WE HAVE
AB EIGHT SIXTY THREE BY VICE
CHAIR FONG. THE PARTY MAY
PERCEIVE ONE READY THANK YOU
CARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF-
FOR OFFERING AMENDMENTS WHICH I
GLADLY ACCEPT. AB EIGHT SIX
THREE CLOSEST TO THE POLLS IN
THE VEHICLE CODE TO ENSURE
SAFETY FOR SOME OF THE MOST
AFFORDABLE DRIVERS. ARE PERMIT
HOLDERS. BEFORE MINERS AND SEEK
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE. THEY
FIRST MUST OBTAIN A LEARNER'S
PERMIT. THE LEARNER'S PERMIT IS
DESIGNED TO EQUIP OUR NEW YOUNG
DRIVERSWITH THE FOUNDATIONAL
SKILLS OF DRIVING WHO
EXPERIENCES THE PROVISION.
BEFORE THEY BEGIN TO DRIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. THE PERMIT
HOLDERS MUST BE ACCOMPANIED BY
AN ADULT WHO POSSESSES A VALID
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND STANDS READY TO INTERVENE
OR TAKE CONTROL OF THE VEHICLE
IF NECESSARY. WELL THE SPIRIT
OF EXISTING LAWS SURROUNDING
LEARNER'S PERMIT. IS TO SPIN
SURE THE SAFETY OF THE NEW
DRIVER AND OTHERS WHO SHARE THE
ROAD. CURRENT STATUTE DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE IN COMPANY DRIVER
TO BE IN THE FRONT SEAT MUCH
LESS OVER. AB EIGHT SIX THREE
CLOSES THESE LOOPHOLES NEW TEEN
DRIVERS ARE OVER THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE INVOLVED. IN
A CAR CRASH BECAUSE NEW DRIVERS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE WRECKING.
ARE LESS LIKELY TO RECOGNIZE
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS ON THE
ROAD AND EXPERIENCE IS A HUGE
RISK FACTOR FOR TEEN DRIVERS.
SUPERVISING A PERMIT HOLDER
WHILE IMPAIRED PUTS THE DRIVING
MINOR PASSENGERS AND OTHERS WHO
SHARE THE ROAD. AS SERIOUS AND
POTENTIALLY FATAL RISKS.-ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT TWENTY
PEOPLE IN THE U. S. DIE IN
DRUNK DRIVING CRASHES EVERY DAY.
THAT'S ONE PERSON EVERY FIFTY
TWO MINUTES. DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF DRUGS OR ALCOHOL
CLAIMS 30% OF ALL DEATHS ON
CALIFORNIA ROADS. AND CHANGES
LIVES FOREVER. JUST LAST YEAR
THE CHP ISSUED OVER FORTY TWO
THOUSAND DO YOU AYE CITATIONS.
AB EIGHT SIX THREE REQUIRES A
LICENSED DRIVER TO OCCUPY THE
FRONT PASSENGER SEAT AND
PROHIBITS BEING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF DRUGS OR ALCOHOL.
WHILE COMPANY HE PERMITTED
DRIVER. AB EIGHT SIX AB EIGHT
SIX THREE IS SUPPORTED BY
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
AND STATE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUPS. YOU WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS COLOR PEARSON WHO IS A
KERN COUNTY. VICTIM SERVICES
SPECIALIST FOR MOTHERS AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TO CALL A LOSS OR SON
ADAM IN A DEVASTATING CRASH
CAUSED BY REPEAT HE Y.
OFFENDER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE OUR FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY- HELLO YES
YOUR HONOR. OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARLA
PETERSON AND I AM A SENIOR
VICTIM SERVICE SERVICE
SPECIALIST FOR KERN COUNTY'S
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
ON ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND TWO
THOUSAND TWO MY SON ADAM SAMUEL
PIERCE WAS KILLED BY A REPEAT
OFFENDER WITH THREE PRIOR DUI
CONVICTIONS AND IT CHANGED MY
FAMILY'S LIFE FOREVER. SINCE
THEN THROUGH MY ROLE AND
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING I
PROVIDED SUPPORT TO VICTIMS
FAMILIES AFTER THEY RECEIVED
THE CALL BUT NO FAMILY MEMBER
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO RECIEVE
JUST LAST WEEK AND BAKERSFIELD
CARRIE LOPEZ TRAGICALLY LOST
HER LIFE AFTER HER VEHICLE WAS
STRUCK BY AN ALLEGED DRUNK
DRIVER JERRY IS SURVIVED BY HER
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
WHO IS NOW LEFT RIGHT GRAPPLING
WITH THE. LOSS OF HER MOTHER
AND- BUT MANY COME. SO SHE-
WITH CRASHES. THIS STORY
HIGHLIGHTS EIGHT EIGHT CHANGE
FATAL CRASH IN BAKERSFIELD THIS
YEAR. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
CRASHES HOUSE DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON VICTIMS FAMILY. AND
EVERY SINGLE DRUNK DRIVING
CRASH IS A 100% PREVENTABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY DRUNK DRIVING IS
NOT THE ONLY RECKLESS BEHAVIOR
THAT MARK OUR ROADS. THERE HAS
ALSO BEEN A STAGGERING INCREASE
IN DRUG IMPAIRED DRIVING IN
FACT 44% OF ALL DRIVERS IN
FATAL CAR CRASHES TESTED
POSITIVE FOR DRUG. THESE DRUGS
MOST COMMONLY INCLUDE MARIJUANA
COCAINE METHAMPHETAMINE AND
OPIATES. TRAIN OUR NEXT
GENERATION OF SAFE DRIVER
STARTS WITH A LEARNER'S PERMIT.
TEENAGERS ARE STILL LEARNING
THE MECHANICS OF DRIVING
VEHICLES AND ARE TOO OFTEN
PLACED IN THE DANGEROUS AND
UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION OF
BEING AFTER DR A PARENT OR
AUTHORITY FIGURES. WHO IS UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL. IT I AM AN EXPERIENCED
COMBINED WITH IMPAIRED
SUPERVISION CAN BE A RECIPE FOR
A DEADLY EXCHANGE. ARE
SENSELESS AND MUST DO BETTER TO
PREVENT EVERY SINGLE ONE. AB
EIGHT SIX THREE CLOSE ARE CLOSE
BUT CHIU IMPORTANTLY POLLS TO
FURTHER PROTECT OUR NEW YOUNG
DRIVERS AND ENSURE BETTER
SAFETY FOR EVERYONE SHARING THE
ROAD MA'AM IF YOU CAN FINISH UP
YOUR AMBLE OKAY GOT IT THANK
YOU YEAH. GO AHEAD YOU CAN
FINISH. OKAY THANK YOU FOR MY
MENTOR FONG FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE I THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIX THREE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND WE ARE VERY
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSING YEAH IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE I SEE NONE
IN PERSON IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE WITNESS FROM. SEEING THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR MOST TO LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
AMANDA GUADARRAMA WITH THE AUTO
CLUB OF SOUTHERN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THEN NEXT SORT TO WIDEN
FORTY SIX. ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS MARLIN ASPECT
REPRESENTING TRIPLE A IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF AB. EIGHT SIX THREE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER LIGHTEN
CHEN Q. THANK YOU OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HEATHER ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YES
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT SIX
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AT THIS MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR FONG I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS. BILL TO THIS COMMITTEE.
OBVIOUSLY IN LAST FEW YEARS
OPIOID ADDICTION ALCOHOL
ADDICTION BUT MARIJUANA
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT IT'S
LEGALIZED- THE NUMBERS ARE
JUST- AMAZING. HOW MANY ARE
COMING AND NOT JUST ACCIDENTS
BUT THAT SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS I'D LIKE TO CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE. OKAY
SING NO MORE IF YOU'RE WELCOME
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL OKAY THANK YOU WE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO FOR PATIENTS FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON OUR
GIPSON I KALRA. COLDER I LEE.
MEDINA MEDINA I. THERE NAZARIAN
I WENT. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I WARD. WARD I WICKS
WICKS I. THE LOTUS FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THAT PHYLLIS
OUT. CAN WE CALL THE ROLL ON.
OTHER ITEMS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CAN WE GET OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE. I AM
NOT CONSENT FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN OF SORRY PROVOKED WILL
ZERO FRIEDMAN I. LEE THIS AREA.
CONSENT YEAH AND I- A FINAL
VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO. REFER OUR
CURRENT VOTE. FOURTEEN ZERO.
OKAY I. THE OTHER ITEMS FILE
ITEM FOR A. B. NINE SEVENTY
FOUR. THEY AREN'T VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO THIS AREA. MISSOURIANS
MISTER NAZARIAN MISTER JERRY.
YES NICE JOB. NAZARIAN AYE
CURRENT VOTE. FOURTEEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB. TEN
THIRTY FIVE. FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI THIRTEEN ELLA AND
INTERFERENCE. AT XERIUM CURRENT
VOTE. FOURTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT SIXTY
THREE. CURRENT VOTE. FOURTEEN
ZERO. BECAUSE EVERYTHING OKAY
WITH THAT WE ARE TURN.